yes thank you very much for organizing
this conference and for inviting me
giving me the opportunity to
some of my research and I will actually
try to bridge the first in the second
panel a [ __ ] not not talked so much
about history from the 19th century but
will concentrate more on the 20th
century and particularly in the first
part of my talk on the last 20 25 years
before I turn to the
Spitsbergen treaty as an approach to
settle the disputes so I will first talk
about these immigrants competition in
the region will then take as a political
scientists view on the power dynamics in
the region before turning to the SCS
disputes as all of you know China and
the US are engaged in a serious
strategic competition of Asia specifics
future regional order and in this
context the disputes in the SES provide
our political powder cake so we have to
see the disputes linked to the overall
strategic rivalry between the US and
China and to the dynamics that have been
taking place in the in the in the power
structure in the regions both countries
are caught or actually the whole region
is caught in a what Graham Allison has
called a to PD District the turkey
leaders trap tries to explain or tries
to bring some importance to the fact
that since 1500 they have been 15 cases
where a great great powers arising red
power and an establishment power have
met each other in an eleven out of these
15 cases there has been war mostly lost
by the rising power as a German I can
tell you this funny thing mmm so this is
a very serious situation there China
rising the US as a established hegemon
and the the SES disputes are in this
context of a political party now let me
briefly come to the seniors competition
as you know China has overtaken the US
GDP based and PPP purchasing power
parity in October 2014
this has been the first time that this
has happened since more than a pallet in
20 years that yes
not had the biggest GDP on the world
neither Hitler's Germany and Imperial
Japan combined with their lies now the
seventh Union but other client states
never had that much of an economy at the
same time China has invested much in its
defense structure always above the rise
of its economic growth its GDP growth
rate mostly in the double digits only
recently single digits but still above
the GDP growth rate and this has led to
consider the changes in the ratio
between the years and Chinese military
expenditures this is a chart from
baseline see pre figures the Stockholm
International Peace Research Research
Institute and it shows that at the end
of the Cold War in 1991 1992 the u.s.
spent almost 25 times as much on defense
as China and within yeah 20 years this
went down to below five times as much if
you look at the latest figures it is
about three times as much if you take
purchasing power parity which would be a
much better evaluation it is about two
and a half times as much so within a
generation we had a particularly an
astonishing a shift in the military
exponential structure moreover China has
been out spending other regional nations
by a particular margin China now spends
all other regions in asia-pacific of the
exception of the years of course so
these are some of the little indicators
that push the narrative that China's
getting richer and more powerful and
fretless the u.s. role in asia-pacific
and that both nations might head for
conflict and however as a political
scientist I was astonished to find out
that there was no political in our
extensive four lenses been done so far
since the end of the Cold War and I took
it up to myself to do such a thing and
power and political science as most of
you will know is a cluster of concepts
there is not a single definition and no
uniform understanding is there so
basically what we can do when we look at
the literature we can distinguish
between three times every
types of power which would be aggregate
power mostly related to realist furies
capabilities resources you have and this
is power from something and tooth times
of power over relational power and
structural power relational power mostly
a connective of the work of Max Viva
Robert da and Morgenthau and structural
power connected to the work of Susan
strange and riposte vltava sugar goo and
others so I looked at two of these two
of these dimensions I could get power
relation power because structure powers
quite hard to to track down to and
should we go actually Argos that it has
checked itself into a dead end
and I did an aggregate power analysis
but again I discovered that there is no
Kanan in IR which generations on which
variables which can base my measurement
various so most scholars used population
territory GDP military expenditures or
what about mineral wealth
what about economics what about food
dependency etc so far there's one
exception to this rake line Ray was the
director of intelligence and research at
the US State Department served as the
deputy director of the central
intelligence isn't agency and was also
the longtime executive director of the
Center for Strategic and International
Studies CSIS and he did he constructed a
composite indicator I used his work and
the work of Ronald fella who adopted his
work clients work in 1998 to formulate a
new composite indicator I get power
which tried to measure the power
dynamics in the region since the end of
the Cold War and it encompasses 54
indicators and is 444 political entities
in the region so basically all countries
of the region was quite a lot of work to
do because it was so much data I only
did five years which are in almost like
10,000 data arrays in five year rows so
have an evaluation from 1992 to 2012
I used to to find out how the power
shifted in the aggregated power
definition and I used a leader legged
standardization which was quite simple
to explain the leader has avoided
hundred points in each category and the
legged always gets hundred and you know
all the other nations are grouped in
between and I used several weighting
scenarios as a sensitivity test and
reliability test so this is how the
composite indicator power looks like as
you can see it basically has three
components critical mass which is the
usual size of population territory then
a big chunk of economic capability
ranging from the domestic economy to
energy supply certain non-fuel minerals
and the industrial capacities the food
production capacities and the position a
nation has in trade and Finance and
lastly of course the very important
segment of manager capability and it was
interesting for me to see that in all
scenarios of course China grew China has
risen this is just one example taken
from the co2 so the second scenario you
must read like this in the beginning
China has like 34 points the US has of
course 100 and in over the time trying
to rise up to 82 so in that time in all
scenarios China is basically catching up
to the United States there was one
scenario which I found quite interesting
in which China outrank the United States
and that was something I didn't expect
to be honest but again that was a
scenario in which I about an equal wage
to all of the cluster indicators so what
I can what we can take from this is in
all scenarios the narrative is true
China's risen China's rises there at
least if you take such a composite
indicator of all its statistical
failures because you what you measure is
what you measure
sometimes you measure the wrong things
so what about relational power analysis
again this has been no standard method
established there are many problems
available but most of them actually all
of them I found very hard to apply to
actual research so I came up with my own
a case study analysis and I looked at
two methods and combined two methods one
is the comparative historical analysis
and the other one the structured focused
comparison and I won't spend much time
on explaining these but when you're
interested I'm happy to explain them
later to you and looked at free segments
political security and economic affairs
and had ten indicators all in all to
look at and I decided to look at not all
the 44 states but it some more important
ones the region of middle powers and for
this I developed a mid-range theory that
loves allows me to attract relational
power dynamics because I argued that
shifting allegiance of middle powers can
be taken as a latent indicator for
relational power [ __ ] so this is quite
simple and if a middle powers allegiance
Vonn by a great power the aggregated and
to something safe the relational power
of that middle power is added to the
great powers regional influence this is
a chart taken from Hans Morgenthau who
was very influential for my work and and
basically sums up what I said before so
if for example is China has more
aggregate power the influence B has the
allegiance to B has one with other
smaller states with lesser powers allows
it to compete with the greater a so what
did the Year lighten partners shout me
first I had to identify emitter powers
in asia-pacific so I did a gay means
cluster analysis for one of the
scenarios and a yielded six countries to
look closer to Australia Japan South
Korea Thailand Pakistan and Indonesia
and in I'd also did of course the
cluster analysis of all the other
countries and info for the other see ups
I did for the other composite indicators
I did and Vietnam was ranked twice as a
middle power and but I decided because
what's the math work to do that I
skipped Vietnam and but I think we're
dumb has the the best option to actually
considered a middle power and
asia-pacific the best not work sorry so
then I did this analysis for c-h-i NS of
C on the bilateral relations with years
in China and I discovered after an
extensive analysis that there is no
general shift in
regions many states actually have
stronger allegiances to the United
States or about the same as 20 years ago
so despite the talk of power shift there
is has not been a relational power shift
the only country where I could identify
a shift in illusions was Pakistan
Pakistan is the most has moved much
closer to China in recent years so this
out and strategic dilemma for China it
has more means but not as much palaces
would like to get in order to achieve on
ends and this is also problem for China
in the SES disputes and in this context
there is a useful lesson taken to be
taken from Europe's past the scholars
have called for creative diplomatic
solutions that are needed to defuse the
disputes in the area and I have thought
about you know maybe maybe we can look
in a diplomatic history and find
something that might be of use to that
region and I found something I believe
it can be of help so this is still very
much work in progress and as you I'm
sure you will find out quite a creative
and splits back what is specific most of
you won't know this um I believe it is a
quite a big archipelago in the Arctic
sea that has been discovered in the late
16th century it is as big as Sri Lanka
or West Virginia and it was very
important in the beginning for energy
whaling the fed was used for perfume
etcetera for meat and and the area has
been contested for for many centuries
the Danish and Norwegian Kingdom client
that the English King client at both
claims sovereignty other countries like
France Russia Spain the level ins and
Germany declared it to be amar Valley
boom so it's a free free area where you
can do what they what you want if you're
one to hunt you've got the right to do
that and this of course led to violence
not large-scale violence but still
people got killed this is another map on
the area in the nineteenth century and
it's back gave the illegal starts of
terra nullius it was an international
free-for-all me meaning that there were
no room
no regulations and achievements to solve
conflicts nor management of the maritime
resources no real exploitation taking
place then something happened in the
late 19th century coal deposits were
discovered big problem why because new
mining technologies made exploitation
attractive and possible and we had a
naval race and an energy race going on
in the region at the time in Europe at
the time so rising great powers the
German Empire France Russian Empire Iran
or we're all looking to that archipelago
we're assessing whether could they could
gain somehow some way or the other and
it took until the Great War until the
end of the Great Wall that regional
states actually came up with a solution
to that problem and I think the
Spitsbergen treaty which is the solution
might be of help for settling some of
the disputes in the SS and at least ease
the tensions there so an article 1 in
the Spitsbergen treaty it is August that
Parties undertake to recognize the full
and absolute sovereignty of Norway so
Norway is granted serenity big
achievement article 2 and free establish
the principles of non-discrimination and
equal access so for example French or
English ships are allowed to to fish and
hunt in the area and go on land
slaughter the animals they want to get
and at the same times the Nationals of
all signatories shall be admitted on a
footing of absolute equality to the
exercise and practice of all maritime
industrial mining or commercial
enterprises and this was a huge step
forward so they can actually see that
the magnitude emerged the terra nullius
concept was that of national sovereignty
both components are in there this goes
even further when you look at two other
aspects limited sovereignty and
demilitarization I call it Norway is
fiscally limited and it's only a now to
levy as much Texas a dues and duties on
Spitsbergen as it needs to administer
the island because it doesn't management
obligation to do managing the
exploitation the mining
expectations it is managing the the
fisheries in these territorial waters
etc and so on for and the past Norway
has actually said
more money on Spitsbergen than it has
gained out of it so mainland taxpayers
are paying for Pittsburgh and very much
important for the assist would be that
Norway is not allowed to create not to
allow the establishment of any naval
base another construct any fortification
and the same territories which may never
be used for world like purposes and in
fact Norway has bent many well had has
argued that military presence of other
countries unwelcome and has only have
very very limited maritime forces there
it's basically English coast guard thank
you very much
and the nice thing about this it's back
and truly is that it was recently put in
Asian Pacific News because two countries
they have 43 countries now who have
joined the treaty and several nations
from asia-pacific China Japan India
Australia and very recently North in
South Korea so South Korea and North
Korea are now allowed to go there mine
fish etc so what can we take out of this
there are three principles which should
be applied to the South China Sea
first non-discrimination equal acces
second clear sovereignity a bit
restrictive there and second effort
final and perhaps the most important
point for Dimitar ization of certain
parts this could bring us in the case of
Spitzberg a durable security stability
and joint economic development in the
region so in a sense a regional power
dynamics integrate power rivalry in the
region must be recognized in VSDs
disputes
china has an arising aggregate power
based as i have lined out it is engaged
mr. Chi competition with the United
States as other scholars present here
will explain later and more detail in
greater detail and it also elects the
allegiance of most regional middle and
small states so it's basically a lone
superpower
there are several aspects that can be
discussed with regards to its bearing
approach I only focus on one aspect here
the question of server entity which has
blocked joint development exploitation
of the ACS so far because China is very
much happy to go
to other nations areas that exploit the
resources there but as unwilling to let
other nations come into the the areas it
claims with regards espera can approach
and sovereignity three scenarios
possible there's one important
precondition precondition and I think I
will take some flag lighter and the
crescent answer section for this but I
think it is a good idea to divide the
SES into three segments the Paracels the
spread lace and Scarborough and I think
given the power dynamics and the great
power great power rivalry China will be
granted server energy over Paracels even
though I believe that Vietnam has very
good historic lamps but I believe that
there's only one a realistic option if
you grant China sovereignty and if you
then go on to discuss the sovereignty of
the second in the third segment this is
an answer to this unsatisfying for many
observers I totally understand this but
I think that the reality of very
powerful acknowledged in this context
China seeks security for its coastal
areas of think I will talk about this
later and given the historic invasions
of Western colonial powers and Japanese
Imperialism it is actually making sense
in this context so the question for the
second of the third segment is who gains
the sovereignty over the Spratly Islands
of Scarborough there are three possible
scenarios first only reach in the middle
and small powers gains over India second
China China's basically pushing through
its nine or actually I think you should
say 10 10 - line because they recently
included Taiwan and one of these dishes
or the current control nations exercise
in the region's is accepted and granted
what might work best I think that
scenario one is probably best because
middle and small powers are not directly
engaged in the great power rivalry as we
can see when we look at the Spitsbergen
treaty Norway a NATO founding member so
very close to the United States upheld
the principles of the Spitsbergen treaty
even in the most intense phases of the
Cold War
so the island was never militarized was
never used for anything to counter
the Soviet units access to the Atlantic
which would have to thank you and in a
sense the territories are strategically
marginalized when you award middle and
small powers the right of sovereignity
based on the other principles including
the other principles of
non-discrimination and demilitarization
which would allow economic operations
like joint exploitation to take place is
the security dilemma and would also
involve the u.s. just like in the East
it's very tricky as an important
signatory who is enforcing rules of the
treaty on the other end the option to
earn free and tailed the dangers of a
what I call a Munich moment because you
can never be sure of a china's just you
know trying to be nice at the time and
will not change the rules of the game at
a later point when it and it feels more
confident and I think we've seen this in
the past with China so in order to to
limit the the likelihood of a Chinese
monitor teen and South China Sea I opted
for scenario one so what is the
conclusion the SES disputes needs to be
needs to be seen in the context of the
u.s. rivalry and original power dynamics
since the end of the Cold War China has
gained concern in aggregated power but
less in relational it isn't an isolated
power it has been no power shift in
asia-pacific that disadvantages the
United States China is a great power and
in that brain power I think we will wise
if we take the security interest of that
great power serious
Chinese extremes have actually fostered
relational power of the Eurasian of
power developments of the United States
so finding finding a durable solution to
the SS disputes is also in the interest
of China simply pushing around weaker
states pushes those states in the u.s.
corner China thus needs to bind itself
by international law I think these
Pittsburgh will approach surf Europe's
trade and middle powers quite well and
seems to me to be a viable option due to
the principles of non-discrimination and
demilitarized demilitarization and I
believe as a signature in the US would
be an important or unsure of the treaty
just like in the case of this respecting
treaty thank you very much